[Music]
hello and welcome to the week in 60
minutes brought to you by spectator tv
and broadcast on thursday december 9th
i'm kate andrews the spectators
economics editor and your host this week
i think it's worth reflecting before we
dive into the show on this week's press
conference and the introduction of plan
b covid restrictions
there are lots of theories going around
about the timing of these announcements
why more mass mandates
working from home guidance and most
controversially the introduction of
vaccine passports were brought in after
being ruled out by the deputy prime
minister just a day before
we'll dig into those theories on the
show but i want to focus now on the
press conference itself
there's been plenty to challenge in the
countless kobe press conferences we've
had on and off for the better part of
two years patrick valance's infamous
chart last october for example showing
one scenario of cases surging and
nothing else
but wednesday's press conference was
another level of spin
what the prime minister and his advisors
were saying did not translate to what
the graphs on the screen were showing us
the metrics that matter most
hospitalizations and death
have been flatlined for some time now so
in order to claim that the data the
science now required new restrictions
rushed in within a matter of hours they
came up with some disingenuous
comparisons
chris witty tried to draw parallels
between the uk and south africa where he
said hospitalizations were surging
because of the new variant
south africa's double vaccination rate
for the whole population is 25
in the uk it's 70
95 of adults in england and in scotland
are estimated to have antibodies 97
of the over 75s these are not comparable
countries
witty also tried to draw comparisons
between our world now with working
vaccines antivirals and much better
treatment and understanding of cobin 19
and our world last year without these
things
he said of the link between infections
and hospitalizations quote you've seen
how things have gone before that's
probably the way to bet
and then if we're pleasantly surprised
nobody would be happier
than he would be
how can that be said with a straight
face it certainly used to be the case
when we didn't have vaccines that a
soaring infection rate saw
hospitalizations and deaths follow
but when the government opened in july
in cases surged we saw how well that
link between infections and severe
illness had been broken by the vaccines
it's not fully severed it never will be
there are still reasons to be nervous
and the government could have laid out
its plan b strategy on that basis the
unknowns about the omicron variant their
concerns about worst case scenarios
about a health service that is designed
to operate on the brink of catastrophe
still unable to cope with any kind of
unexpected plot twist
but to claim that plan b is based on the
data
the data we have right now
it doesn't add up
and to claim last year's experience
without vaccines should be looked at to
compare to this year's experience with
vaccines and boosters
why are they talking down the jabs
this spin would be a problem at any time
but it matters now especially accepting
the principle of vaccine passports
fundamentally changes the relationship
between the individual and the state
this is a landmark moment and the
government has taken this leap without
any evidence that we need them and
without any evidence that they work
across europe even within the uk we can
look at scotland these passports have so
often failed to make any meaningful
difference
over half of this year has been spent
living under some level of coveted
restrictions we weren't able to sit on a
park bench with another person for three
months this year because we were told to
hang in there the vaccines are the
solution and they are the solution
but
what's the solution now
if they're saying this is no longer the
case what's the exit strategy for
reversing plan b and frankly at some
point ditching the rules that still
existed within plan a
how can we trust they're going to follow
the data when they spin it so
ruthlessly does anyone believe that next
monday when working from home guidance
comes in that ministers in whitehall
will be following it
nothing this week or the entire pandemic
would suggest that rulemakers are
subject to what they mandate for the
rest of us
and on that note on to this week's show
vaccine passports are a go for
nightclubs and big venues working from
home is back and boris johnson wants to
start a national conversation about
mandatory jabs the pm introduced new
covert restrictions as his government
was floundering over a party they
allegedly didn't have last december
do they have any credibility i'll speak
to our politics team
the omicron variant is spreading fast
through the uk how serious is it we'll
speak to professor aleister grant
it was meant to be the government's
crime week where they unveiled their
plan to crack down on drug usage and to
try to help people into rehabilitation
dame carol black who came up with the
plan and former tory leader anne duncan
smith will join us
is russia about to invade ukraine putin
held crisis talks with biden earlier
this week as troops and weaponry have
massed at the border but is nato making
the situation worse we'll speak to owen
matthews and former nato advisor angela
stent
and finally give me give me more britney
spears content it's the story of the
year let's be honest and writer sarah
ditham reviews the book being brittany
in this week's magazine she'll be on the
show to tell us what she thinks
before we get going if you enjoy
spectator tv you should subscribe to our
youtube channel just click the red
subscribe button at the bottom of this
video and tap the bell icon to make sure
you never miss an episode
and why not subscribe to the spectator
magazine too you can get 12 weeks of the
magazine and a free 20 pound amazon
voucher for just 12 pounds to take up
the deal go to spectator dot co dot uk
forward slash tv offer
first the prime minister announced new
restrictions yesterday but after the
number 10 party fiasco does his
government have any credibility i'm
joined now by katie balls and isabel
hardman
katie to you first it's been a big week
in westminster give us the highlights
yes i think
lots of things in there happened but
ultimately i think where the point when
the dial moved was uh leaked footage um
of a practice dining street press
conference
in which senior dining street staff
appeared to joke about a christmas party
allegra stratton at the time the prime
minister's spokeswoman um being asked by
a number 10 staffer at oldfield
ultimately uh you know there are reports
of a downing street christmas party um
suggesting that this could be something
she might get in a real briefing and
then the various people in the room
joking about how to respond to that
before saying oh the camera's on
and then saying oh it's definitely a
fictional party now the reason this is
particularly uh curious is there's been
reports rumbling on for about over a
week now
about a party that occurred in downing
street on the 18th of december cheese
and wine um lots of different things and
it appears to be a reference to that
at a time when boris johnson and his
team have spent days and days denying
any such party existed and i think that
really opened things up the prime
minister has now called for his cabinet
secretary to launch an investigation
into the party allegra stratton has
resigned and it's all looking rather
messy more claims and questions being
asked about various parties in 10
downing street
and then you add to that the prime
minister's decision yesterday to
announce that the uk is moving to plan
beyond covid in the face of the omicron
variant and that raised eyebrows amongst
his own mps who've really taken it back
because senior figures in government
have been saying we can move to plan b
but we're still getting the data in i
don't expect you know anytime soon we
have a review period um
just before christmas and that's from a
look at things so it felt as though uh a
rapid move forward and the prime
minister has been accused of almost dead
catting it trying to bring in something
else to dominate the headlines the
problem for the prime minister as you
can see in the various front pages and
at the end of this week is that it
appears to be saying
we will be doing uh one rule for downing
street staff we can't follow
restrictions too hard but we expect
everyone else to have more restrictions
so he is facing hypocrisy charges and a
very angry tory party already fed up
about the fact that they are having to
defend things which are tricky to defend
and that may or may not have occurred in
downing street and uncomfortable
conversations and now also fed up at the
fact that new restrictions are coming in
many of them question whether things
like vaccine possible are really
necessary or effective
isabel a lot to dig into there as katie
mentions this all built up to the
resignation of boris johnson's former
press secretary turned cop 26
spokesperson allegra stratton
do you think that her resignation takes
the pressure off the prime minister is
he going to get away with this so to
speak this idea that the buck stops with
her
i imagine that's his hope that was
certainly his strategy at prime
minister's questions this week where he
effectively threw his staff under a bus
by saying he'd received repeated
assurances that there hadn't been a
party
which in effect was him telling the
commons that he didn't know what was
going on in his in his own building
admittedly quite a large building number
10 downing street is
deceptively uh big um and also that he
thought that his uh his staff might be
lying to him which again is uh
not the mark of a strong leader one way
or the other if you if you think your
staff are lying to you you don't know
what they're up to and you think they're
probably disloyal to you as well which
which isn't great but this was his
strategy for being the person who
survives this and gets other people to
take responsibility uh on his behalf
i think that'll be his hope but talking
to conservative mps i don't think that
that's what's happening um
not least because uh allegra stratton uh
who obviously lots of us at the
spectator know uh her statement uh
this week
was very sincere and was couched in sort
of moral terms in the way that the prime
minister would probably never um speak
and a lot of conservative mps and
ministers who i've spoken to since that
statement uh were quite upset by it
actually because they felt that somebody
was taking responsibility in a way that
the prime minister should have been
and they felt quite a lot of sympathy
for stratton given she did as the leaked
video
showed us not even go to this party that
everyone was joking
about so
i think conservative mps feel that
someone else needs to be taking
responsibility
they expect that there will probably be
more members of staff but what they
would like would be for it to be the
prime minister and they don't just mean
it in terms of him actually
telling the truth from the outset when
accusations of parties are being leveled
they also mean
um him
uh taking responsibility for the cove of
restrictions the ongoing covert
restrictions that as katie said they are
getting more and more upset about so at
the start of this week you had former
prime minister theresa may who i think
it's fair to say now is is a serial
rebel on the conservative benches but
isn't you know one of the covert
recovery groups sort of locked down
skeptic
um mps complaining in the comments that
the government was continually turning
the economy on and off again and that at
some point it needed to learn to live
with covert and i think that the
combination of a downey street as katie
said that appears not to be able to
follow its own rules while still
announcing restrictions on things um
it has really upset conservative mps and
has really damaged um what was already
quite precarious loyalty to the prime
minister
and speaking of those backbencher mps
katie we now have tory mps who are being
openly critical of the prime minister
once again tiana davidson william ragg
angela richardson have all come out to
say they disagree with the government's
plan for vaccine passports the pm has
faced rebellions on covet measures
before so do these frustrations that are
being voiced really matter look at the
moment it seems labor will support at
least the bulk of these measures and
that was the strong suggestion in the
chamber when sergeant javid
facing calls to resign from his own mps
but actually was streeting the new
shadow health secretary and finding
support so
i think the bulk will pass some asking
questions over vaccine passports but
generally speaking it seems boris
johnson will get his way but that's not
the end of the matter um it is a very
dangerous situation and an uncomfortable
situation for a tory prime minister to
pass measures on labour votes on
opposition votes and the fact you have
this many number of tory mps already
coming forward saying they disagree
they're not going to do this um you have
the whole weekend to go before you get
to that vote some members of the payroll
i've spoken to really um
adding things up very uncomfortable not
sure whether to go through with this i
think it could be the biggest covert
rebellion we've seen to date from the
tory side and this is a tricky place the
prime minister's got himself into
because i think it's that double whammy
of your own team uh the building you're
in charge of you might say you don't
know what's going on and ultimately
you're in charge of that ship so if you
don't know there's questions on your
grip if you do know there's questions on
your honesty and also by the way when we
add to the many things that happened
this week have um a new judgments over
the downing street flat refurbishment if
um viewers can think back to bring that
to that with the electoral commission
finding that the party for um
the way it uh reported the funding for
that and now questions about whether
boris johnson um lied about what he knew
as and when um but i think the sense
that boris johnson and his team have not
been following the rules to the letter
boris johnson's team combined with the
new measures and the sense that if we
are on a trajectory now by which you
will
ultimately have
cases going up that's something that
will then concern the government and you
could potentially have new measures
borah johnson is going to be between a
rock and a hard place and i think this
time actually it could be even more
difficult
um for the prime minister because last
time around when his opposition and
when his mps were opposing him you had a
situation where he could promise
vaccines well a lot of people are
vaccinated what is the prime minister's
um answer to omicron is it that booster
jabs we're seeing that a bit but i think
there's a wariness amongst mps that they
thought they'd got through this
if we are heading to even tighter
restrictions going into january and
others um i do think the prime minister
is going to struggle to sell that to his
party isabel what do you think the
bigger threat is to boris johnson at the
moment the number 10 christmas party or
the coveted restrictions
it's the new cove of restrictions
the number 10 christmas party and the
way in which he's handled it
have uh aggravated all the feelings
within the conservative party but i
think
there's a
i think it's probably wrong to say that
the public will
stop obeying covert restrictions because
of what downing street were doing a year
ago i think it's too simplistic because
if we look at what happened after the
barnard castle
um
affair
actually people continued to obey
lockdown restrictions and um people
continued to support lockdowns for
far beyond that incident last year um i
think what it does do is it undermines
trust within the parliamentary party i
think um it undermines um
the prime minister's authority in
announcing these restrictions and that's
why these restrictions are the bigger
problem uh because
he is having to
swerve certain issues as well so we have
the bizarre situation and reflected in
the front pages
today where you are being told to work
from home from monday uh but go to
christmas parties which just doesn't
make any sense i mean perhaps our
workplace is very standoffish but but
but i think that generally at a
christmas party you tend to have more
social contact than you do when you're
sitting at your desk in the office by
and large
that that does tend to be the case
katie last question to you what is your
sense of how things are in number 10 at
the moment are they calming down as you
move into the end of the week or are
they still very frazzled
well look i think it's a frazzled team
and also you think about the owen
patterson row
boris johnson and his team in number 10
have been facing negative headlines now
for
several weeks um i don't think that's
about to go away i think the departure
of allegra stratton has actually raised
more questions um if someone who didn't
attend a party that may or may not exist
depending on who you listen to um what
about the people who might have attended
this party um it almost uh sets a path
in motion by which you would think more
people would have to go
if you the level by which you're going
on is you know joking about this party
surely that people who were there would
face tougher
you know sanctions from from their boss
and so i think that's keeping going
those were asking about more events and
you have dominic cummings who keeps
pushing this idea um of a party in the
downing street flat to celebrate his
departure
um and obviously lots of people have an
agenda here but these are the things
downing street is going to have to field
and then again questions coming back
about the flat refurbishment at a time
when there's lots of tricky things with
covered so i think getting to the end of
the year is looking uh uphill
and
what we need to remember too is next
week is the north shropshire by-election
that long-time tory's safe seat owen
patterson's former seat he stepped down
as a result of their um sleaze scandal
it still would be a big upset if the
live dems were to take that i think a
lot of people would be surprised but the
tories are increasingly nervous about it
and i think that if you see that
majority which is over 20 000 um
sufficiently slashed um if it goes
yellow i think that's a whole new
territory and again that is another
pressure point for boris johnson that he
really doesn't need
thank you katie thank you isabelle
there's no doubt however that the new
omicron variant is spreading throughout
the uk
how bad is it professor alistair grant
from the university of east anglia has
estimated that the r value is around 3.5
remember we were told it needed to be
kept below 1 to keep things manageable
he joins me now
professor thanks for coming on spectator
tv
how much omicron do you think is in the
uk today
okay so
i'm actually working from official data
so i'm working from the same data that
the
official advice is based on um
i can put the results of that analysis
out
faster because i don't have to go
through the formal check to make sure
that i've got everything absolutely
right before it goes into the public
domain
so based on that
on
6th of december so that was
tuesday
um
about
six percent of
the cases of on the crop the cases of
cavity that were detected in england
were
probably
omicron that figure is probably higher
in scotland i don't have access to the
scottish data but it looks like the
numbers scotland seems to be somewhat
ahead of england
and
numbers there are likely to be higher
than that
and we still don't know a lot about this
variant the work is patchy at best we
are getting more updates every day but
what do you think are the most important
things to highlight about the variant
right now what are you seeing that's
consistent in the studies that are
coming back
i think the consistent pattern that's
coming back is that the variant is
growing very quickly
numbers are doubling
roughly every two and a half days
that's consistent with the pattern in
south africa it's consistent with the
data from denmark
so wherever we look at it numbers seem
to be doubling around every two and a
half days
what would that mean for omicron in
terms of competing with the delta
variant in the uk
they actually won't compete
they're in effect to independent
to independent organisms there
so delta was interesting because so
often last winter anyway and when we
moved into february march time there was
talk about how delta would overtake kent
so you're suggesting that perhaps
they're actually going to operate
independently and we won't see a similar
overtaking scenario
eventually there will be an overtaking
but delta will probably
delta has been at around 50 000 cases a
day for
since late summer
and it's likely to stay at that level
and omicron will come in on top of that
so
um
at the moment
about six percent of cases are omicron
that is doubling let's say if it doubles
every three days then
that will rapidly come up to the same
sort of numbers as
delta but it won't displace delta
because delta infections are propagating
independently
if measures are introduced to limit
transmission that will lead to a
reduction in delta
um
but
they're not really in competition at
this stage that's really interesting is
there anything that we can see that's
consistent about the way that omicron
patients are faring once they're
infected
it's really too early to say it takes
about a week from initial infection
before people are hospitalized
so
the numbers are growing so rapidly that
a week ago there were very few patients
very few
very few cases
and
those people will just be
at risk of hospitalization over the next
few days
so you think perhaps by this time next
week we're actually going to have a lot
more data about this
we over the next one to two weeks we
will start to get information as to
whether
patients suffering from omicron are
more or less likely to be hospitalized
there are some suggestions from
elsewhere that it may be
slightly less severe um so the risks of
an individual who captures omicron
may be
reduced
but if the numbers increase then we may
be dealing with a
a smaller individual risk but a bigger
total number
as
greater numbers become hospitalized so
in your experience what's the best case
in the worst case scenario over the next
few months now that omicron is clearly
circulating in the uk
so
we're really at the stage that it's hard
to predict what will happen
and that will depend on the extent to
which
booster doses protect the elderly who
are the most vulnerable to severe
illness and it's too early to say as to
how much protection there is
it's the information that's available
does does indicate that boosted assets
are
reasonably effective against omicron so
get your third get your boosted days
if you're eligible
um
but at the peak of the epidemic
then the majority of people hospitalized
and the great majority of people who
were dying were people who were over 80
because the risks of severe outcomes
increased so steeply
with age
we've seen cases amongst the over 80s
decline very steeply
as booster jams have started taking
effect
so the real uncertainty is whether those
numbers amongst the elderly will start
to go up because that's where the real
pressure on the hospital systems will
will come from it strikes me that that's
one of the two major data points to look
at
but as well the general question of
severe illness um is is the other there
does seem now to be a pivot back to
focusing on the infection rate over the
summer when the government decided to
push for reopening the focus was on
hospitalization rate strikes me that the
really big question that hopefully will
have answered sooner rather than later
is even if the omicron variant does
undermine the effectiveness of vaccines
to some extent when it comes to being
infected
does it impact how sick you get and if
the vaccines are still protecting from
severe illness
surely that's the major thing to be
focusing on
yeah so there does all the indications
are is that there is a significant level
of protection of information against
severe illness
but
the numbers are rising so steeply that
the real concern is that even if only a
small proportion of those people are
becoming seriously ill that will put
pressure on a hospital system that is
already under a lot of pressure many of
our hospitals are
working incredibly hard to catch up on
the backlog from throughout the pandemic
and
adding additional coded cases is is
going to make that worse so we're
already seeing reports of hospitals
spending many
ambulances spending many hours outside
of hospitals
a number of hospitals have are on the
highest level of alert
because essentially they're full
and
that's before we're seeing any pressure
from on the crown
it does it does seem that these
conversations very often come back to
nhs capacity uh well let me ask you on
that point what do you make of the
government's announcements this week
that we've moved into plan b we're going
to see um a push to work from home
unless you want to attend a christmas
party then you're going to be encouraged
to come to the office
there's going to be more mass in public
spaces and most controversially the
introduction of vaccine passports for
large venues
do you think that these measures are
going to curb or at least slow the
spread of omicron
they should help
exactly how much is
is not clear
but i think
anything that we can do
to
limit the spread of the virus without
having major consequences for people's
liberty and for the economy is something
that we should be doing at this stage
until the picture becomes clearer
professor aleister grant thanks for
joining us
this week was supposed to be crime week
on monday as boris johnson watched
merseyside police raid a house in
liverpool suspected of drug dealing the
government announced ambitious plans to
cut drug misuse
under the plans 300 000 of the most
vulnerable drug users will be targeted
for rehabilitation and nearly 800
million pounds will be invested into
drug treatment
but drug deaths in the uk this year
reached a record high is their plan
enough i'm joined now by dame carroll
black who suggested many of the
proposals taken forward by the
government in her independent review of
drugs policy and by former tory leader
anne duncan smith
carol to you first what do you make of
the official plans the government is
bringing in well the plan is in three
parts and those three parts are all
important
the first part of the strategy is
enforcement so very much
home office affairs the second part
which is the one i know most about of
course is treatment recovery and
prevention and that part is based very
much on my part two of my report and
then there's a section on recreational
drugs where we really as yet do not have
a good evidence base for what to do but
i recommended in my review that we had
an innovation fund
so that we could start to build that
evidence base and decide what
interventions would really make a
difference to quite a difficult problem
and what do you make of the plans
well carol's right how the structured i
think
i think the government is now finally on
the right path
uh but there are some issues obviously
that arise with it i mean i went through
this back in the 2010 to 2016 period
when i was in government for six years
where we had already agreed in
government that we would do more to move
drugs policy over towards rehabilitation
and away from what i'd felt become the
pernicious maintenance idea and put this
in context what happened with the
previous labor government was that they
said they were going to tackle drugs and
drug addiction and what they then said
was that they would have a a checklist
against how many people they had managed
to get into treatment the problem is
that they counted anything to do with an
interventionist treatment so those who
are maintained on alternative drugs like
methadone etc
many of whom
ended up for years rather than months as
a pathway drug stuck on this very
addictive drug and at the same time
quite often taking illegal drugs as well
but they were in the tick box marked
they were in treatment with an actual
fact nothing could be further from the
truth and the areas where they really
would have been in treatment such as
rehabilitation either day rehab or
long-stay rehab
these found progressively less and less
money available to them so the warning
we failed at the end of the day to get
the policy exactly as we wanted it
because too many departments had a very
narrow view of their wants home office
only wanted people subdued so they were
quite happy for them to be years and
years on drug substitutes the health
department felt that the whole idea of
keeping them out of hospitals as far as
possible on substitutes worked
and therefore the rehabilitation which
is more expensive but ultimately much
more effective
and started to go by the wayside that's
got worse over the last few years so
this government policy now which will be
focused massively in the middle of it
on rehabilitation
is a good move but it's going to be
something they have to fund and the
final point i'd make on this many years
ago i visited sweden the swedish policy
which i think is arguably the most
successful drugs policy uh in the
developed world is where you face
addicts with a choice
they either take a criminal route or
they go into rehabilitation and they
fund their rehabilitation and if you
fall out of the rehab you go back into
it again until you get clear of it and
signed off on it so that's the position
we need to be at but we are some way
away from that
carol anand's point about rehabilitation
when you dig into the policy that's
actually being proposed um he's right it
is really emphasizing rehabilitation not
only significant chunks of money now
going behind helping addicts to get
their lives back on track but for
example there's going to be a 33 percent
rise in placements for rough sleepers
and the idea now is that if the police
come across somebody who is rough
sleeping automatically the assumption
should be rehabilitation rather than
imprisonment and yet the way that the
government's been talking at the start
of crime week um has been all about the
crackdown all about the enforcement all
about getting tough on crime why isn't
what we're being sold the the rhetoric
the the short video clips lining up with
what the policy actually entails which
is far more thoughtful
um
well indeed the
the media has picked up on the
enforcement but really they've also
picked up on rehab and
treatment and if you really want to get
on top of drugs
you have got to reduce demand you will
never reduce addiction by just thinking
you can reduce supply you need at least
a 50 50 balance and what i was trying to
do in my report was to bring together a
whole systems change so that you will
have good clinical care you will have
mental health and trauma-informed care
you will have access to safe housing
and you will have the possibility of
finding employment you can't just get on
top of addiction by thinking you're just
going to provide as ian says a script
this is a whole systems approach
requiring central government and
requiring local government to work
closely together
and i don't think it's just the media
that's picked up on the enforcement
though it's very clear that boris
johnson and his government want the
media to be focusing on the crackdown
aspect is that because he's worried that
voters think that your party is becoming
less tough on crime
look every government including the
blair government
needs to catch a headline
and the truth is that the idea of
rehabilitation that is to say long-term
getting people who are significantly
addicted to all sorts of substances
illegal and often legal substances
stable again and off and and out and in
the world and working
that is not a kind of sexy subject what
is always eye-catching for governments
and particularly for uh the the media
is the idea of cracking down on the
suppliers
and cracking down on people who casually
buy drugs
not thinking of the consequences for
crime on the streets death
and uh violence
and so um it is always going to be like
that but the key question that really uh
is one that i think runs all the way
through this is we still need somehow to
be able to be talking about this so that
we get it done i know a particularly uh
brilliant rehabilitation center that
changed my focus on how it can be done
it's up in buxton it's run by
a woman called noreen oliver who herself
was an alcohol
addicted to alcohol and got herself
through and she set up this brilliant
rehabilitation center if anybody wants
to know what rehab looks like
it's about getting people off drug
making sure the doctors are there with
them and at the end of the day moving
them through an employment process so
they're able eventually to move out
back into the world of work it is quite
staggering success rates of places like
hers but they lie behind the news all
the time because nobody really wants to
know
about that because it's not as sexy as
the headline of cracking down but i
honestly recommend to any journalist if
you really want to see what the future
could look like you need to go and visit
a place like that and if you come away
uninspired then you really yourself
probably need to go into rehabilitation
to rediscover the great things of life
and in 2018 you were vocal about wanting
more stop and search to crack down on
the drugs trade but you also seem very
welcoming of this more thoughtful
approach that's come in this week to
focus on rehabilitation have you changed
your mind over the past few years no no
no no no you you've got to understand
that these things are interlinked as
carol said earlier
we had the center for social justice
which i set up have for years been
arguing
that there are there are a number of
areas you have to target you have to
interdict the supply of illegal drugs
you have to try and therefore force the
price of illegal drugs up which we know
corresponds with lower levels of drug
taking
but critically you must try and save
lives to get people off drugs so things
like stop and search for the police are
critical if they're to interdict that
supply process and break up the county
lines the gangs dealing i'm in a you
know borough that has
often gang warfare going on over drug
dealing territory so you need strong
policing no one argues against that but
as carol said earlier on strong policing
alone doesn't solve the problem it just
does that point of pushing the price up
by making supply much less and therefore
it puts a squeeze on numbers taking it
but alongside that you've got to take
the people out who are addicted to this
rehabilitate them back into society so
they don't take drugs and therefore you
help squeeze the market demand at the
same time all of this has to be done
together when i made those comments
about stop and search i said the police
must have those powers because the young
kids etc who are moving weapons and
drugs around
the gang leaders know that they won't be
stopped because of the then regulations
and therefore they use them if you want
to stop it you've got to be able to get
the police to be able to do that but
there's a much wider perspective and
i've known that for
well over a decade with the center for
social justice
carol you were talking before about
supply and demand when it comes to the
drugs trade and if i look at the basic
economics of this a zero tolerance
policy isn't going to quite stack up the
global drugs trade amounts to roughly
one percent of worldwide gdp in the uk
alone it's estimated to be worth roughly
uh 13 billion or roughly 10
billion pounds i mean you can talk tough
you can threaten the middle class with
taking their passports away a lot of
people won't believe it'll actually
happen and even if a few of them do and
change their behavior this is not going
to convince everybody to stop taking
drugs recreationally
is a zero tolerance policy essentially a
prohibitionist policy really the right
one because even with all the discussion
of treatment which seems very positive
the government hasn't moved away from
that principle that it wants to
eradicate drugs it just doesn't seem
like a real possibility to me well as
you probably know in my report i wasn't
asked and neither did i look at
legalization
or decriminalization of drugs and i
think there was plenty to do without
going down that line you can make this a
public health issue you can make drugs a
chronic condition you can make it a
health condition and do all the things
that ian and i have talked about without
changing the law and there is a huge
difference between the 300 000
heroin and crack
drug dependent people
who cause about forty nine percent of
serious acquisitive crime about fifty
percent of homicide and occupy a third
of our prison places
and the drug dealers earn about nine
billion pounds
and the total cost to
the uk is 19.2 billion
and those who take recreational drugs
people who take cocaine
think that this is not a problem but you
really have to remember that cocaine is
part of an international drug trade
every time someone takes their cocaine
on a saturday night they are driving an
international trade that starts in south
america through albanian drug gangs down
to people um on our streets and having
their parties and it drags in young
children who become part of
of the county lines system i don't know
none of us knows yet what would make
someone think twice
before they do that what is it that we
have to do to explain and to get a
change in behavior so that people don't
think cocaine on a saturday night
is a good thing
thank you anne and thank you carol
over the last nine weeks putin has moved
more than 90 000 russian troops to the
borders of ukraine us intelligence
thinks he's preparing for an invasion
in this week's magazine owen matthews
says putin could be more rational than
we think to explain he joins me now with
angela stent a former advisor to nato
supreme ally commander in europe
owen in the magazine you look at nato's
response to russian aggression towards
ukraine what do you think nato's getting
wrong
well
for a start of course we're not in fact
responding directly to a russian
aggression yet we're responding in a way
that's predicated by former russian
aggression and we're responding to a
possible russian aggression and the
evidence for that um certainly from the
sources that i've spoken to as widely
reported has been intelligence reports
that putin has not only mobilized troops
on the ukrainian border but also
implemented detailed tactical planning
of a possible
um of a possible
invasion
but my point is actually to take a
little bit of a step back and examine
the premises on which that response is
being made
and the question is
really of my piece is
given that
ukraine can never
join nato until its
conflicts with its neighbors and its
border conflicts are resolved those are
just the
rules of nato membership
why are we pursuing a
a policy which
essentially puts
ukraine and its territorial integrity
front and center of
nato policy
and i think it's worth
uh questioning or examining uh the
extent to which that is actually
destabilizing rather than stabilizing
the situation and in practical terms we
as the west certainly britain and the
united states and canada and various
other nato members have been rather
active in
uh giving
military support to
uh ukraine and that is being cited by
putin as the proximate cause for his
mobilization plans
so the the issue is really um
what are we
how can we proceed with ukraine that
signals strongly that uk ukraine will be
protected in the case of russian
aggression but at the same time sort of
de-escalate the situation with putin and
in a nutshell the question is and it's
not a question i ask very often but
it's not something that
i say very often but
um is it possible that putin actually
has a legitimate security concern that
um the way nato is behaving
has given him rise to believe that
eventually nato will accept ukraine as a
member and that is a very clear red line
for him
angela what do you make of that owen
questioning whether or not nato's
assistance could be the cause of not the
solution to putin's aggression
well i think we've got this all wrong
right the reason why ukraine has a
security problem is because russia
invaded ukraine in 2014 it annexed
crimea it invaded the southeastern
part of ukraine it instigated a war
there the people who are fighting there
they're not separatists these are
russians and russian-backed proxies and
so they created this instability and and
and this major military catastrophe
really for ukraine and an ongoing war so
to say that somehow russia should feel
threatened there was absolutely no
reason why russia went in and took
crimea in 2014 except that it wanted to
it had a
someone in power in kiev uh president
yanukovych
who fled the country uh because of
demonstrations against him so the
origins of this problem are not nato
it's what russia did to ukraine and
since then um as i said the fighting has
gone on
unfortunately in 2008 at the bucharest
nato conference there was a communique
and this was a result of a compromise
between the germans uh and french and
the americans saying that one day
ukraine will join nato um it would have
been better if that language wouldn't
have been there because for the west it
means sometime in the very distant
future but obviously the russians can
point to this and say look ukraine might
join nato but the you know the current
build-up there has really nothing to do
with ukraine threatening russia the
reason why uh ukraine has been getting
military assistance is because of this
persistent war instigated by russia now
i read um owen matthews article with
interest um but i think there's
absolutely no proof that if
you know somehow the us and russia were
to decide over ukraine's head that it's
never going to join nato whether that
would really change russian behavior i
mean putin wants ukraine to come to heel
he wants a government in kiev that will
be subservient to moscow he's
essentially said that in all of his
writings that's what his goal is and the
nato part is the excuse for him uh to do
what he's doing
owen
all right well dr sten i mean i i
certainly about your superior
experience i mean you've actually been
uh a senior military adviser to the uh
to nato's security as surprise supreme
allied commander in europe so clearly
you have heads on experience but i would
nonetheless take issue with a couple of
things you said firstly um i was
actually in donbass in 2014 and uh
they're not russians they're separatists
i mean there are russians among them
doubtless i mean there i i certainly saw
some some russian security officers but
i the vast majority of people that i saw
on the ground and i saw hundreds of them
were actually locals of dumbass they
were separatists so actually to deny
that its uh separatist movement is you
know just factually incorrect um the the
i have no issue whatsoever with your uh
with your timeline that's uh it's
entirely true putin is to blame um for
the most of these
destabilization within ukraine although
it must be said that actually even pre
uh donbass and pre-crimea the
ukraine also had a different unresolved
conflict and that's transmis
so actually the uh um the
it's it's not the sole cause of uh
ukraine's problems with potentially
joining nato and uh let's be very clear
i mean i there is uh uh
i'm not victim blaming here i'm not
saying that the ukrainians should stop
um aspiring to nato because indeed if
you're from the point of view of of
ukraine it is the proximate ally to
which to go to protect itself from
russian aggression
however that being said i mean i think
there is a
uh a major uh
dialogue of the death going on here um
that actually uh
the west continues to
support
ukraine militarily in frankly
non-militarily decisive ways that
continues to be uh a point of major
contention with with putin and his uh
what you say is the main excuse for his
aggressive actions um all of that is
true
but the problem is that um you touch
you touch it with a needle i mean do we
think
that actually putin's long-term intent
is actually to reintegrate ukraine
somehow into the russian empire now as
you rightly say dr stent
putin's writings especially for putin's
writings this year
have based on clear
fundamental
misinterpretations frankly ignorance of
ukrainian statehood that's also true but
actually do we really think that he is
an investor in imperialist that is
obsessed with actually reintegrating
ukraine uh even at the cost of
destroying his own economy i mean i
frankly don't think that that's the case
angela what do you think
i think the solution to this and
apparently this did come up in the phone
call yesterday uh between biden and
putin is to revive the completely
dormant minsk agreements which haven't
gone anywhere that was supposed to
resolve the crisis signed in february of
2015 that the united states should be a
full participant in this at the moment
it's france germany russia and ukraine
and maybe great britain maybe some other
countries but certainly the us and go
back to basics and see if there's some
way of working out a diplomatic
resolution to this now this assumes that
the russians want a solution to this and
other than you know ukraine saying that
we'll never join nato we don't know that
but it should certainly be tried and so
i think that is the way forward at the
moment is to re-engage um all the
parties in these negotiations see if
there's uh a more productive way of
resolving the question of the status of
of these two self-declared republics in
the donbass
owen a few british mps are whispering
that a war in europe could be just weeks
away do you think they're overreacting
yes they're overreacting um
they're basically sort of swallowing the
kool-aid and doing putin's job for him
because what he wants the
the reason why you rattle sabre is
because you want people to hear that
saber rattling so actually all of us are
kind of uh uh dupes in that sense of
actually of putin he's he's he's he's
he's staged a credible uh credit of a
credible stunt he's mobilized his troops
the troops on the ground and all of us
are actually just helping his agenda by
sort of raising the the temperature the
ukrainians that must be said are also
party to that because uh to to raising
the the temperature because um uh i'm
not doubting that they seriously believe
there's a there's a russian threat with
troops matching on your border why would
you not but also they have their own
agenda which is actually encouraging um
as nato to support them as to a greatest
as greater an extent as possible um i i
think actually i mean um security
sources that i've spoken to actually
don't see any kind of realistic scenario
and including ukrainian security sources
don't see any realistic scenario for the
kind of widespread invasion um that um
the mobilization suggests certainly not
from the from the directions of the
troop concentrations from where it's
coming in other words from the
bel-russian border in other words
threatening kiev i mean that thing
that's not that's not going to happen uh
the ukrainians are actually more worried
about uh the ukrainian military
intelligence people that i've spoken to
i'm much more worried about a possible
sort of salami tactics um around
mariopol and around the sea of azov and
that kind of thing but um i think
neither of those are actually going to
happen i think putin actually wants to
reach a grand deal and as dr stent has
said
once again like uh you know you're you
are a nato insider so i'm inclined to
entrust you
to to respect your analysis i think
you're exactly right that actually minsk
is the key to this and minsk like in a
tiny nutshell is um ukraine gives
internal autonomy to uh donbass
donetsk and lugansk um and russia and uh
in exchange it gets control of its own
eastern border back again angela last
word to you how do you gauge the current
threat level
so i also don't think that an invasion
is imminent
i agree completely and and particularly
a full-scale invasion you know where the
russians tried to get to kiev uh it
would be a bloodbath the russian
population is the doesn't want don't
they don't want their sons uh fighting
uh in ukraine there was enough trouble
when body bags were coming back in 2014
and 15. so um this isn't like crimea
that was very popular the annexation so
there's a domestic
aspect to this too um so full-scale
invasion going to kiev is off the table
the salami tactics is possible um they
would like to uh take mario paul to have
a land bridge to crimea
to sort of uh secure their dominance
around the sea of azeroth and everything
but even that would obviously evoke one
assumes that would also evoke the kind
of sanctions uh that we heard about
yesterday after the call with uh between
biden and putin so they probably will
hold off on that i think the prospect of
sitting down and negotiating uh will
appeal to them because it will show
putin a kremlin that uh the west takes
their concerns seriously
again going back and seeing how mints
could be better implemented um not
having so many disagreements on the
sequencing of the implementation of this
agreement um so i think um i think
there's been hype about this that was
probably excessive and in the beginning
the ukrainians themselves said no we're
not worried by the russian troop
movements and it's only more recently uh
that they've changed their tone on this
which is which is interesting uh but
nevertheless i think the reason why the
u.s intelligence agencies did get
concerned and did apparently brief all
of our allies uh in some detail about
what was happening is if you look at the
numbers of troops the formations and the
kinds of things you see going on there
it's very hard to have a rational
explanation for why that's happening
and you might believe in the end that in
fact the point is intimidation of
ukraine getting the u.s and other
countries to the table again but you
can't if you look at the capabilities
and you're not sure about the intentions
you have to at least consider the fact
that an invasion might be
really possible but for the moment i
don't think it is
owen angela thanks for joining spectator
tv
and finally after some toxic years for
britney spears she's come out stronger
the other side in this week's magazine
writer sarah dittum reviews a new book
called being brittany which says that
the pop star was devoured by 21st
century media and celebrity culture she
joins me now
sarah thanks for coming onto the show
you reviewed jennifer otterbecker dyke's
book being brittany pieces of an icon
what did you make of it
um
i think it's um
well researched but probably not the
kind of final word on britney spears the
the world is necessarily waiting for
and so
um
she's obviously done stacks and stacks
of research and pulled out loads of
detail out of the archives but at the
same time the story the sort of overall
liniments of the story she's telling are
pretty familiar to anyone who's watched
things like for example the new york
times documentary that came out earlier
this year
um which is a story of britney that goes
like
child superstar massive success
hunted by tabloids and paparazzi
understandable breakdown
exploited and overtaken by the
conservatorship which
is imposed on her in 2008 and under
which her father for the most part
is able to entirely control and
often benefit from her career
and then up to
the present day so it has actually um
was completed and published i think went
like the final version went to print
just before the conservatorship was
wound up which means that it's in the
kind of you know
like i feel bad for her it's awful when
you write something and the deadline
passes before a sort of a major
development in the story happens and
you're just sort of left going
oh
like oh story happened without me then
oh that sucks um and that is
unfortunately what's happened to this
book so it kind of
you know has this sort of question
hanging over it like can brittany ever
be free and now the answer is yes yes
she can and we know that um
so on the one hand it kind of suffers a
bit from
timing which is you know an inherent
problem for anyone writing a book and
can't really behold against her on the
other hand um
the other thing it suffers from is
just telling quite a familiar story of
what is quite a familiar subject at the
moment
you say in your review that it also
falls within the term known as the
brittany revisionist era what exactly
does that mean
oh okay so basically um when i talk
about the britney revisionist era
i'm talking about the fact that there's
been a really sharp shift in the way we
talk about brittany and the way we talk
about pretty much all female stars of
her era um over
i would say kind of the last you know 24
months pretty much it's been a pretty
recent thing that we've gone from a sort
of a general understanding that someone
like brittany was ruined by essentially
her own
trashiness
in the most unsympathetic version or
just bad luck in the more sympathetic
version to
an understanding that people like
brittany like paris hilton
um lindsay lohan and you know all of the
other people who will be remembered as
sort of major train wrecks of the
naughties and were actually the victims
of celebrity culture and that and this
is true i think like the revisionist
interpretation has got a great deal of
you know virtue to it because
for a very long time these have all been
treated as people who were kind of the
authors of their own misfortune um
when they were actually very much
experiencing the sharp end of a you know
a very novel and very cruel form of
celebrity that kind of emerges out of
the
formant of the internet culture plus a
sort of a generally
scabrous attitude to celebrities that
comes up in the naughties um
so um after 9 11 piers morgan
makes this big announcement that he's
like he's had it with celebrities and
he's not going to have any more truck
with like being nice to them um and
makes this big and like a journalistic
statement about how celebrities are
going to have to fear him and the mirror
from then on um which is only slightly
pathetic if you know that the reason he
makes that announcement is that he's had
a big bust up with richard and judy
about coffee approval and that his um
like the way he kind of enacts that is
by starting the 3am girls the gothic
columnists
but that is kind of the attitude to
celebrity that is dominant in the
naughties and just essentially screw
these people they've got something that
they don't deserve and we're going to
make them suffer for it
this this new narrative doesn't just
seem like it's good news for brittany
seems like it's potentially good news
for many of us if not all of us if you
look at these sense that um her journey
has brought so many unexpected people
together i think it was for a time in
the united states that the republican
party and the democratic party which are
just completely on polar opposite ends
of the spectrum right now actually
decided to unite over the free britney
cause i know and i mean with the free
britney thing especially it has this
added element of
um
sort of reflecting the entire
conservatorship issue which um i knew
very very little about before i started
sort of looking a bit more into
britney's situation and the more i
learned about the more i was like holy
heck california has an actually evil
legal system for people ruled mentally
incompetent um because it's essentially
like it's the equivalent of power of
attorney but it's so totalizing that it
gives so much um authority to the people
who
operate the conservatorship and has so
little opportunity for people to be able
to actually get out of it once they've
been placed under it and brittany is
obviously you know the most high profile
person to be under a conservatorship but
it's pulled focused what is
um essentially a kind of
what sounds like illegal battery farming
of people's estates in california and as
you can imagine california is especially
ripe for that kind of thing because you
have lots of old movie stars who might
have very valuable assets that uh
you know an unscrupulous attorney can
take control of so you know um
so yeah there are like issues that kind
of draw out of these things and can be
talked about as wider political issues
as well it's not just you know trivial
celebrity stuff
let me ask you one more question how do
you think britney spears is going to be
remembered do you think she'll be
remembered for being a pop star
sensation
or for this case over her
conservatorship which became a struggle
for personal freedom
i think it depends an awful lot on what
she does now so
there isn't a huge sense
yet of whether she's going to be
interested in going back into recording
and performing
um which is obviously you know like in
the sort of early days of free britain
of the free britney movement it kind of
starts because she goes on this
indefinite hiatus in 2019 when she
decides she's not going to perform or
record anymore because she's basically
sick of her dad having so much control
over her
so the fans kind of come together
because they are motivated by wanting to
see her perform again
but nothing she said so far really
suggests that she strongly wants to go
back to doing that on the other hand
she's not disowned it either and so she
like um i think in some of the videos
she's made to celebrate her freedom
she's used work [ __ ] as the background
of music so it's obviously like still
there for her it's not something that
she has
totally negative associations with
um
but
at the same time
you know
if she decides at this point what she
actually wants to do is have another
baby get married to her incredibly hot
fiance
and just
live a relatively quiet life making
slightly erratic instagram videos i
think everybody would be quite happy for
her i think that would work fine
sarah thanks for joining us
and that's it for this week if you
enjoyed this episode don't forget to
subscribe to the spectators youtube
channel just click the subscribe button
at the bottom of this video and tap the
bell icon to make sure you never miss an
episode thanks for watching and do join
us again next week
[Music]
you